da ist er wieder karl marx in seiner
ganzen revolutionären pracht die ikone
des kommunismus in bronze und das beste
zum geburtstag gibt es die statue gratis
chinas geschenk an die trierer es ist
ein symbol für die zukunftsträchtige
freundschaft zwischen deutschland und
china
wenn das so einfach wäre
die rechtspopulistische afd gibt kontra
wenn auch diesmal schweigend
ausgerechnet die partei die sonst
fremdenfeindliche sprüche klopft pocht
auf menschenrechte für die opfer des
kommunismus erklärt sie karl marx
verantwortlich und will ihn vom sockel
stoßen drei straßen weiter
das gegenteil sozialisten kommunisten
marxisten feiern ihr idol und drohen die
revolution steht unmittelbar bevor
mal wieder als am marx denkmal die
dazugehörigen flaggen auftauchen da wird
deutlich dass es noch immer ein
schwieriges verhältnis ist zwischen marx
und den trierer von rechts noch von
links landrat die ihre afd ist diese
doch ganz nah dran
die chinesen lässt der krawall kalt sie
sind ja zum glück für die demonstranten
hier in trier nicht zuständig die stadt
empfängt die delegation wie bei einem
staatsbesuch
auch darüber wird in trier gestritten
bietet man sich zu sehr an muss man
nicht viel mehr distanz zeigen zudem
land in dem menschenrechte wenig zählen
wenn wir unsere deutschen maßstäbe
anlegen und nur mit staaten reden die
die gleichen maßstäbe erfüllen im sinne
von pressefreiheit und und und
sein zimmer ziemlich alleine auf der
welt ein kopf aus marx zitaten das
deutsche präsident fordert viel vom
chinesischen gast um das zu genießen
brauchen die leute die sich mit
marxismus auskennen und die sind im
heutigen china wohl seltener anzutreffen
als in trier
der oberbürgermeister ein gefragter mann
im chinesischen staatsfernsehen er ist
stolz auf den größten sohn der stadt
trier ist nicht das neue karl marx stadt
trier ist 2000 jahre alt die älteste
stadt deutschlands aber kann marx gehört
zu trier dazu eine karl marx straße gibt
es hier schon länger allerdings etwas
verschämt in einer eher finsteren ecke
am rande triers
jetzt bekennt man sich offensiv zum
markt marketing die andenkenläden machen
kasse mit allen möglichen souvenirs zum
jubiläum ein schönes beispiel ist unser
0 euro schein max hat gesagt er würde
das geld am liebsten abschaffen weil er
konnte ja auch selber nicht besonders
gut mit geld umgehen und insofern
bezieht sich dieser 0 euro schein
das hat man in einer ironischen weise
auch auf marx und auch auf marx
geldtheorie was mag selbst nie geschafft
hat kapital schlagen aus dem kapital und
manch anderen devotionalien so viel
geschäft sind verwirrt dann selbst die
chinesischen gäste lautete 20 35 eine
grundlegende modernisierung des kapitals
des sozialismus erreichen oder doch
umgekehrt der neue marx made in china
wird wohl auch das verkraften nicht nur
in trier